la pratique est un bon soir le thème de
la conférence de ce soir la rupture
amoureuse
qu'est ce que c'est et surtout comment
la vaincre tout d'abord je vais
présenter je suis les afficheurs c'est
paris depuis 33 mois huit semaines et
bientôt le 7h ce recul face à la
séparation aujourd'hui me permet de
venir vous voir et d'échanger avec vous
sur le sujet puisque j'ai mis au point
une méthode pour guérir d'une rupture
amoureuse
voilà bon avant de rentrer dans le vif
du sujet ce qu'il ya des personnes ici
qui n'ont jamais vécu de rupture
amoureuse
oui non vous peut-être monsieur vous le
fais pas le droit de s'inscrire sur
votre visage inutile de regarder les
autres de haut ça vous arrivera peu de
personnes lèvent le doigt et c'est
normal parce que selon une étude menée
par le magazine love attitude 99.999 9 9
9 24 5 7 8 % de la population mondiale a
déjà vécu ou vivre à une rupture
amoureuse
voilà bien je vais donc expliquer qu est
ce que c'est qu'une rupture amoureuse
afin que vous ne soyez pas largués sur
le sujet
donc une rupture amoureuse
c'est donc deux personnes qui est
amoureuse qui ne le sont plus
compliquées j'ai fermé schéma on voit
donc très clairement ici de cellules moi
j'ai dessiné des cellules parce que
j'avais pas dessiner les êtres humains
et qui m'ont fait quand j'étais petit je
dessine beaucoup de soleil la leur on
voit cette fois je dessine aussi c'est
super beau donc ici une de cellules qui
sont rejoints par une membrane interne
qu'on appellera l'amour jusque là tout
va bien
les deux cellules sont en osmose on est
clairement dans la relation dit
amoureuse d'un gala c'est vraiment après
qu'on eut d'abord des dégâts donc ça
c'était mes vacances à biscarrosse
pardon je sais pas ce que ça fait là
mais ça aussi
bon ça c'est la duke duke il a bon avec
mon ex on avait loué un petit chalet en
bas c'était très sympa c'était super
cosy et en fait c'était très drôle parce
qu on s'amusait à l'est sur la great et
on avait loué déluge médicinales et du
coup mairie attends je vais venir je
vais te fait lors des yeux
donc là on est clairement dans la
rupture amoureuse
les deux cellules se sépare la membrane
interne et distendu voilà donc rupture
amoureuse dans le jargon scientifique on
appellera ça
une démo l'accusé risque une délocalise
une des molécules les rays une cassure
entre deux cellules émotionnel voilà bon
ce que je vais vous dire c'était un
petit peu copieux intellectuellement
pour certains d'entre vous je vous
propose donc de faire une pause
la pause
fin de la pause voilà bien je vais vous
faire une expérience ce sera peut-être
un peu plus 5 pour comprendre la rupture
amoureuse pour ça j'aurai besoin de
quelqu'un dans le public on me sens très
honoré ses batteries glorieuses qui va
faire bien alors voilà on vous allez
mettre la main contre la mienne on va
essayer de reproduire le schéma qu'on
vient de voir dont nous sommes les deux
cellules un les êtres humains et si la
membrane
il faut vraiment mettre sa main comme sa
part voilà on remet la main comme ça
donc voilà n'hésitez pas à mettre tout
votre poids 1 voilà on tient donc l'un
contre l'autre on est dans la relation
amoureuse mais vous allez voir
qu'est ce qui se passe si jamais il est
pas coutume
sans toi je vais faire voir mais si tu
parles moi je dis donc qu'est ce qu'on
voit dans l'expérience il est parti je
suis donc tombé on comprendra alors que
pour se remettre d'une rupture amoureuse
il faut se redresser et récupérer son
équilibre voilà pour ça j'ai la méthode
mais avant je pense qu'elle est
nécessaire de faire une autre pause
fin de la pause
et bien pour pour trouver ma méthode
j'ai fait des recherches des très
longues recherches pendant pendant très
longtemps j'ai regardé les gens dans la
rue j'ai regardé sur internet j'ai lu
des livres j'ai regardé les dessins
animés et je me suis rendu compte que
tout le monde passe par les mêmes étapes
lors d'une rupture amoureuse
ce n'est donc pas quelque chose de
personnel mais quelque chose d'universel
l'humanité entière est touché par ce
fléau
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui j'ai trouvé neuf
étapes clés d'une rupture amoureuse
d'où le nom de ma méthode c'est voter
mcb éphémère qu'il reprend donc les
initiales de son côté m
mais j'avais un bon plus tard pour le
moment je vous propose peut-être de
parler un petit peu de ces étapes donc
le choc le déni la tristesse du
marchandage des valorisations couvert
fausse joie nostalgie et enfin
reconstruction voilà bon on va peut-être
pas tous les cantiques et aujourd'hui
mais on peut en voir peut-être deux ou
trois par exemple le choc
dans le choc ça va c'est dans le choc
alors c'est un choc parce que depuis
tout petit on nous bassine avec le
prince et la princesse la princesse qui
doit sans don mais le prince attendait
bouge pas je mentais chercher si la boxe
à la dragon je n'avais pas du bluff et
attention à toi où ils ne paient pas
sinon eh beh oui je les oublie à côté de
mon deuxième cheval
attention dragon
tu vas confort ouais je suis beau aussi
bien des livres et non je peux pas
monter la tour pourquoi parce que j'ai
mal au dos c'est que c'est une super
idée de lancer les cheveux ils sont
super long oui j'ai pas de montant de
coupe ongles de s'achever
tout ça dans ma tour alors j'arrive pas
à me faire des trucs high tech bon ben
c'est pas grave je te prie de coupe au
carré non c'est trop bon dieu je
n'arrive jamais comment mater je sais
mais je vais me faire mal non gagne ici
mais je n'avais pas vu elle vient
d'apparaître mais tu fais ça vachement
bien ouais je fais une lamentation
synchronisée dans le lavabo dans mon
donjon c'est l'amour bon bah là qu'est
ce qui se passe
la princesse repart directement son
donjon bon après un donjon de cesser
c'est vrai que c'est un peu grâce à lui
mais enfin bon on peut on peut faire des
choses on peut on peut mettre de la
découvre on peut mettre des tableaux on
peut mettre des photos de son ex
non bon c'est vrai il ya un dragon en
bas mais le dragon peut on va faire des
choses avec ses draps compte on peut
apprivoiser
on peut lui apprendre des mots honteux
on peut la mener à des barbecues
on va voir une autre étape
la tristesse la tristesse étape très
importante dans une rupture bon dans
cette étape il est très important de
beaucoup beaucoup s'hydrater
on pleure énormément on est dans une
sécheresse intérieur donc s'hydrater
énormément très important on a déjà
retrouvé dans cette étape des femmes
lyophilisés on va peut-être voir aussi
la nostalgie qui est une étape assez
importante
bon la nostalgie c'est va quand on est
en manque de câlins on est en manque
affectif on a besoin de se faire serrer
dans les bras non mais encore une fois
il ya des il ya des solutions qui sont
plus ou moins rares
mais il ya des solutions et arrête
j'étais me reinhart et arrête tu es bon
moi je par exemple
bon moi j'ai pas tomber sur ce genre de
choses mais moi j'ai trouvé d'autres
d'autres solutions là par exemple je
suis à l'alimentaire mans et je fais
quoi
j'étais aux gens que je connaissais
défunt ainsi ils ont pris dans les bras
c'est quelque chose qui a beaucoup
beaucoup marcher dans ma rupture aussi
j'ai dit à mes amis à ma famille à mes
proches que j'avais un cancer du pool à
l'apport affectif a été très très fort
et est ce qu'il a bien c'est que sa
durée dans le temps il rappellerait
prendre des nouvelles icc vraiment c'est
aussi ça dure plus en longueur cac 40
elle manquait finalement il mais voilà
donc c'est bien beau toutes ces étapes
peuvent se vivre de différentes durées
selon les personnes concernées c'est
vrai que par exemple un punk anarchiste
s'en remettra au bout de cinq minutes
tandis qu'une adolescente peut ne jamais
sans en être un alors pourquoi pourquoi
c'est plus long pour certaines personnes
et bien tout simplement parce qu'on
passe trop de temps dans chaque étape
voire même ont fait des retours en
arrière
voilà alors pourquoi et bien c'est très
simple on voit des petits détails qui
nous rappelle notre relation passée un
poil dans la salle de bain
une brosse à dents oublier sa lunette
des toilettes relevé le regard de ce
pauvre chat que vous aviez pris à deux
qui n'est jamais venue récupérer pauvres
petites bêtes petites choses tout seul
abandonné attend toujours ses croquettes
s'inquiète poche
tout va bien pour éviter de vivre toutes
ces étapes trop douloureusement
je vous propose donc de les vivre en une
minute
c'est à dire que alors d'aujourd'hui les
étapes d'une rupture amoureuse peuvent
se vivre entre un an voire 12 ans pour
les plus faibles
mais moi je vous propose de les hydra
grande vitesse ce qui permet encore
d'analysés de broyer de traiter
l'information en direct
voilà je vous rappelle le nom de ma
méthode cdtm des cfnr démonstration
colère non en fait c'est lui c'est lui
tout foutu en l'air
salut c'est la nouvelle copine elle a
l'air très intelligente
ça va super phosphate soir voilà je vais
très très mal oui oui moi aussi je rends
compte pas telles sont les constructions
gelé des chips antichars de déchirer
j'avais dit aux gars de construction
j'avais beaucoup mieux ça va je vais
bien j'ai pas besoin de tout doucement
bien donc voilà la méthode pour savoir à
quel dosage utiliser cette méthode c'est
très simple on prend la taille de
l'individu qu'on divise par le poids de
l'ex conjoint on va avoir un résultat
qu'il faudra diviser par deux pour les
hommes et x 148 x pour les femmes bien
cette conférence s'arrête là vous pouvez
me retrouver sur je viens de me faire
larguer point fr alors mais je suis
aussi sur les réseaux sociaux sur wii
beurre bieber twitter et hinder je vais
partie aussi de l'association tristesse
et eau chaude et j'ai les allemands
publié un article dans le magazine
solitude
voilà je fais aussi j'interviens au
milieu scolaire j'ai fait un ouvrage un
livre pour les enfants qui s'appelle le
prince charmant est un gros fils de
groen
je peux intervenir en milieu scolaire
bon voilà la conférence s'arrête là je
voulais juste vous dire que cette
méthode marche
bon voilà je voulais juste vous dire que
je crois fermement cette méthode moi
depuis que je le jeu utilise je récupère
du temps pour moi je j'ai appris le
mandarin roulage
je me suis mis au boomerang aussi non je
fais des choses très très simple très
simple un jour je crois que complètement
apte à rencontrer de nouvelles personnes
ça va ça va
je fais un câlin au sol masque ça fait
du bien celui-ci rouge c'est le sait
l'amour le rouge lors du procès moi j'ai
bien je suis pas je reste un peu ça vous
embête pas je suis pas souvent alors
j'aimerais bien en fait discuter si vous
voulez
ça a été choisi on va y aller
la cheville il faut y aller c'est fini
et là je pars mais tu vois pas parce que
je suis des mouvements super super
action en fait il faudra un microscope
pour les voir c'est ça tu moment je suis
en train de partir mais la forêt berti
vogts moi je sais ce que je fais on va
très bien alors je c'était la dernière
conférence
j'espère que ce premier tedx nouméa vous
a plu je voudrais remercier donc à la
technique en fait donc christophe
philippe site est aussi sylvie et c'est
d'autre que numéro et cédric numéro 2
merci d applaudir enfin voilà alors on
espère bien sûr pouvoir vous proposer
tedx nouméa l'année prochaine merci
d'avoir été là présents à cette première
conférence de nous avoir fait confiance
à bientôt
merci